you meet a girl you really like
ish would you get married and have kids
now
if i met a girl i really like would i
marry
you we did
zoom in
did you get married and have kids like
now like next like three years
yeah yeah yeah what about you want to be
married yeah that's the ultimate goal
okay
but like you want side checks that's
what i'm hearing
i would never cheat
black men black men don't cheat that's
right
anyway this is like
girls i don't need a man yeah okay okay
she don't need nobody she don't need no
man he wants to be seven i saw i saw the
death in your eyes when you said the
same funani for 50 years
so yes
my man needs how many side chicks you
need
how many wives do you want i said me and
jess are looking to be sister wives just
you know i said is unrealistic for a man
to be with one woman uh-huh i feel like
it is yeah people find that
controversial
but it's like you know he didn't catch
it okay so your ideal are you having
like more than one wife one wife bunch
of side chicks you want sister wives
yeah yeah sister one your situation at
the moment is your friends
i have friends exactly else
yeah
sister wife he's avoiding the
sister wives sister wise be good we're
gonna we're gonna do a dating show okay
we're offering since we're getting close
to 30 we're fifty percent off so we're
in a two-for-one special okay so what is
this in tape
okay so we want bunk beds right yeah
yeah and we really just want to hang out
with each other
yeah yeah and
like we want to split the household
chores you know
um i'd like a house at some point yeah
yeah at the moment i'm just not sold at
all
we would okay so essentially
yeah
you would have no drama from us you
would be able to
whatever day you needed us call us
boom i need you here this time blah blah
okay bet if it's if it's me or pearl
whichever one you need it we're at your
disposal yeah yeah yeah we're just there
we'll do the cooking the cleaning we'll
be the typical housewives and then i
gotta trust them we'd be good money-wise
yeah would you do stuff together
what do you like
oh would you say
you see i'd rather i'd rather just take
turns
i'd rather just take we could be like a
schedule you know
jess you go first and and and we're cool
with one more sister wife as long as she
has to share the room with the bunk beds
we're big under the bunk side okay yeah
yeah
yeah but he didn't answer the question
i said i said no i said we're taking
turns oh it's just like haunted it's
like okay
no i just you know yes
she said peace out people
yeah no honestly i'm not good with
sharing okay if i'm gonna take turns if
i'm gonna do it's gonna be
me i'm gonna be the all-star of the show
can we like we could give each other
like pointers
yeah i'm gonna sit there
she couldn't even imagine it
no no pearl arch like this pearl
leg up like this there you go coaching
yeah yeah
yeah pearl
all right
anyways um that system this is the new
version of the bachelor
like two like
first season will air like december you
know yeah yo they should do that
what sister wives that's what i'm saying
like because i just feel like we're
we're hitting our walls you know
so just speak for yourself
right i'm 23. i'm 24. i feel like it's a
good offer
two for one would you guys would you
guys accept that sarah if you're still
in the chat would you want that yeah the
two for one special
saurus
yeah it's like it's like you know it's
the best of both worlds
chocolate and vanilla guys guys be like
i don't have a type well great
unless unless you want a short girl
that's out i'm sorry but the great thing
is like we raise athletes here
we don't we don't we don't raise kids on
jv
no
so that's okay it'll be great because
i'll coach the kids right so i'll be in
the backyard from like the time they're
five being like making sure they know
that their love will only be given if
they can learn how to dribble right
yeah i like five i'll be like you you
want you want attention
follow through all right follow through
sleep makes sense yeah
that's an interesting one
bulletproof
what
shut up yo
eddie said he's accepting sister wives
[Laughter]
oh okay chat eddie said he's taking the
offer oh the sister wife yeah the sister
wife offer
wow i was chatting [ __ ] i didn't
take it
someone called eddie called it that was
just funny
we'll have our people talk to your
people we'll send you the paperwork and
everything
see that you knew
we'll see how the terms and conditions
what eddie's off yeah do we get
like okay here's the thing i want bunk
beds okay but i'd also like a second
room
where i could play my guitar in good
question does this come into play
next year
because you're definitely moving
i mean we still have the plays yeah yeah
i just
yeah foundation yeah yeah
i just i mean if they if they act up we
just go back to our place yeah right
it doesn't sound like i'm winning here
[Applause]
anybody else what what would y'all just
adding to the rotation right wait
someone said my tic-tacs back in the
comments but i feel like they're playing
with me
ebony and
why would you do this to me he said i
went d1 so they gotta go pro
exchange
put up or shut up exactly
we we've been offering this to people
for a while now oh yeah they don't jump
at the bit
yeah
we go to your room sarah
we're not our room isn't for that that's
why we have bunk beds we're just there
to sleep we go to you
i thought we made that clear yeah like
because we gotta we gotta follow they
lead we follow yeah exactly
you come to the room
pearl
yes okay how does it work there's seven
days in the week we know we could do it
could be like a competition and the
person that like could i put it does
better each week can get the extra day
you mean because it's not an even number
of days i'm sorry you ain't about to get
that extra day
yo i'm a yo yo yo i'm sorry
you're okay you better work your car for
it okay
it is late
okay
let's talk
how are your knees let's talk about your
knees yeah my knees are perfectly fine
really because you don't have an acl
i didn't have an acl one two years ago
and it's still
work you don't need an acl
yeah we could maybe we could like offer
to the highest bidder it could be like
an auction yeah yeah
do i want to get auction off that's a
little
mad do i want to get auction off i mean
come on
can we stop acting like we're above it
we're on our wall
i don't want to get auctioned off
i was born in 1994 not to get auctioned
off so
legit i mean they can send me money
send peas yes send peas
what does sarah say
sorry are you
speaking mad in the chat
sarva said we're making him reconsider
sarah
someone said a super chat they said ish
you better start making more money to
pay for those bunk beds
yo
yo i don't [ __ ] where i eat i i eat here
so we ain't messing around with this i'm
good i'll pass off on the offer not that
it was even off sorry sarah sarah says
he says no or he said i'm fine with that
what guy
the legend
sorry man come through no he said i'm
working
you work from home i'm kidding
real sister wise of the red pill someone
said
look at it look at it
you two gonna make a name for yourself
when someone said more nagging two wives
i said they said the crap
that's what i said to my dad i was like
dad everyone in the manosphere says
you're cheating
because my dad my dad's in like top one
percent of earners and they're all like
oh they have side chicks and i'm like
dad where are your side chicks
and then he's like yeah
um
[Music]
deal with one woman before you gotta
deal with multiple that's too much work
he ain't lying
i put in my bed
someone said he's putting in his bed
okay how would okay hear me out
he said
he said plus i need my oh yeah
for one special yep
yeah highest bidder
two for one
yeah and two for two for
please read the terms and conditions
yeah
the red pill sister wives
someone said one of the members said
please title this
the better title is the red pill sister
wife
i'm putting my bid in i need both of
y'all every day plus i need my songs
dunking in the sixth grade i'm telling
you we could have a whole training oh
best believe we could
i work here so
uh
just it just i'm just here oh someone
said oh 90 free to pie said i'm 6'4 we
can make some sport legends together are
you athletic you can be 6'4 and
unathletic
huh you got to be athletic
no someone said go to dubai cough up bid
[Music]
show my chest
could that be you huh
you know they didn't dubai oh hey
we can make sports legends together
heck no
yeah let's see let's see let's see your
offers guys um
one day
someone said
nightingale 21 said two for one special
each girl one day
date night saturday saturday night movie
night on sunday night monday night
chilling with drinks with butt pearl
with
non alcohol itself yeah how would date
nights go would you want to okay would
you want to share the date nights or
would you want to be like special like
each of us i mean sometimes we can share
it yeah we get along but sometimes i'm
like i wasn't oh i don't want to talk to
you pearl okay
how would you how would you feel if you
felt like he was giving me more
attention than you
that'd be cool honestly i'd be like okay
no i would be i'd be like okay cool
from your so-called man
we're sister wives i get it but he's got
a favor if
if i if i was first and then pearl came
in the picture and then he started
giving her more 10 then i would feel
away
but
so what's the difference of you both
coming in at the same time and then
because without more attention he's just
giving pro more attention
that logic makes no sense whatsoever he
just i i can't explain it he just he was
just like pearl moore there'd be
something that pearl has that i don't
have that he likes to be around more
and i would i wouldn't what about if po
came first
you came second and he liked to pull
more
is that a problem
no because pearl came first but if
you're first
pel comes second and he likes per more
there's a problem
it's not really like there's a problem
it's just
it would suck i'm not gonna i'm kind of
a jealous [ __ ]
yeah see
thank you thank you that's what i look
like i'm not i'm not
like i yeah i don't
but i feel like if we went in knowing
we'd be sister wives like i could come
at it because we're we're the wives you
know like i i come in knowing
yeah
but
ain't nobody been in the chat so
let's see let's see
let's see the
the um
i mean once you go puerto rican would
you go puerto rico puerto rican
yes
okay let me know in the chat we get bunk
beds or two rooms we're okay
we're okay with two rooms i get i get
bottom bunk though i when i was in
college i rolled off my bunk bed and i
separated my shoulder
and the thing is my my bunk bed was over
like it was taller than me so it was
like over a six-foot drop yeah i do have
the hospital that night yeah
i like was sleeping and i woke up and i
was on the floor i was like this is not
good and you had like no barrier
yeah
you have to see the way we set it up it
wasn't a smart way like i wouldn't
recommend it
um